Graphic elements of your user interface
can change appearance to reflect
the different states they're in.
For example, they may change appearance
to show that they are checked, or
pressed, or focused, or
even some combination of that,
such as both checked and pressed.
If you were making a web app you
would define these states in CSS, but
in Android we use state lists.
States lists are XML files that
list the assets to use given
a particular state of a UI element.
You just give it a range
of resources for
the different states and
everything is taken care of for you.
So here's a state list for
check boxes drawable.
It uses different images for
each of the defined states.
When the check box is just checked,
it uses this image.
When it's just pressed and
not checked it uses this one and
if it's both checked and
your finger is pressed down on the check
box, it should use this image.
And by default, and in this case
where there are no special states,
it just uses this default version.
When using a stateless drawable for a UI
element, Android traverses the selector
and looks for the first item that meets
the minimum criteria for the state.
So if you want to use an image to
represent multiple states, such as this
one, pressed and checked, that should
be above the more general ones.
Now, the interesting thing about states
is that you can even create your own.
While there's things like pressed and
checked, and focused and
selected and activated, and really
a lot of different types of states,
you can even create
your own states to map
to whatever your application needs
to represent in its UI elements.